i also mike bethel for those who are not
watching if they're just listening i
imagine what are we on is this like this
yeah
right now i guess even though it looks
like a robe i want to imagine
that it is 100 uh onesie
like it is just that there's a zipper
and there's pants and footies
i would like that i would like that
where did this come from
yeah this is yeah this was this was me
the other day complaining like my old
dressing gown i've had since i was like
20.
a dressing gown what's it called what do
you call this
a bathrobe yeah that's not a dressing
gown mate
i want a dressing gown now though that
sounds like a 100 thing me
well no a dressing gown exists that's a
different thing though
is that it's okay what's this
okay so that's it so this genuinely is
in uk stores called a dressing gown with
hood
oh it is a dressing gown then all right
okay so here's another question if you
could go into
your ice box refrigerator whatever the
[ __ ] you called it so sorry apologies
from here yeah there is a continuum from
the silk dressing round to the
like the furry dressing gown they're
both considered the same thing
it's my favorite so far my brain is just
really going over can i keep this in
is this bit yeah should i keep this in
the show like this whole time i've been
like maybe i could keep that in we've
generated like three and this is
irrelevant comments and
five oh my god dressing gowns are
actually this you can always
engage with this is perfect well also
if you can just i don't think you can
yeah i don't think you can cut it
because
twitter voted this this was this was uh
this was
the show you're right i've got to keep
it and just edit around it
yeah it's going to be a tough one but i
guess that's the show hi everyone
welcome to another episode play watch
listen
i'm milan i've been in games media for
like eight years oh that's too funny
what is this point by austin wintry
video game composer how long have you
been doing what you do austin i don't
actually know
85 years about 85 years i
yeah i eat a lot of carrots so i wear it
well but it's 85 years
um yeah 15 years how long have i been
doing i'm going to switch to shitty
audio
how long have you been talking for troy
well i started
on radio i started out in radio that's
no i always wanted to be in radio and
oh he won't let me do it it won't let me
do it
it won't let me do it weird oh
microphone that's what i want to do
um wasn't it's what option were you
trying to press
microphone dressing down he was trying
to select dressing now that sounds
i sound shitty now don't i so yeah but
it should work though all right
um i i started off so i
was a musician and so like when i was
like
20 26 maybe 25 26
is when i first walked into a studio and
i was like hey can i do that and they
were like okay
and they gave me money for it um and
that was only because the guy who had
done their car adverts for the last 20
years had a heart attack and died and
left the client high and dry
and so i just did what i always heard on
the radios like they saw they saw they
sounded like
like that whole [ __ ] and then that i'm
gonna need a library of that
oh dude there that's going to exist
somebody sent me one
and it was the scariest thing to think
back about it was like scared to fly
this summer then drive to grandma's
house
and the reason why was because who is
that september
it's the guy that there was look i
might can tell you this i steal like i
have stolen stuff i i did a um
uh a gig once with um oh god what's his
name
ah man he's got the coolest voice he was
in
um robin hood minute or not men in
tights
uh prince of thieves um
uh no he played the gravel voice guy he
was also in
oh brian blessed no no i wish
um oh man
he's got like the craziest
and he's a british cat no he's not a
british cat actually he just always
plays british ha ha
that's why i love him so much anyway it
doesn't matter but like i've like pulled
from different people that i've grown up
listening to and i was like i'm gonna
use that voice but it just naturally
sounds different coming out of me so
it's original enough to pass so it
doesn't sound like it's parody or an
imitation
but it was um that's just what i did
like growing up like i made up funny
voices or i i just tried to sound
different and mainly the reason why i
did that is because i didn't like the
way that my natural voice sounded
every time i picked up the phone and
someone called and i was like hello
they're like hi
is the man of the house there is like hi
mrs baker and i'm like
i'm a boy and it was just like it got me
so i always try to change my voice
um and then i remember the the time when
all of a sudden was like man
i said in a session it was like it's
easier to be dirty than it is to be
clean it was like
besides the fact of that sounding like a
johnny cash lyric that's true about my
voice
because i just done so much screaming
and yelling that trying to maintain a
pure tone was actually harder
than just like getting that gravel
whereas it used to be easier to get the
gravel
so then then i was like i wish i had my
like old tenor voice now instead of this
beat up one well but at some point
during that process where you you know
showed up and started yelling in boots
and were doing voices and stuff did you
take acting lessons because there's
definitely obviously a difference
between just doing voices
and acting is this a subtle uh yeah
he's a very good actor just think about
maybe like how did that pot occur
i have relationships right
yeah i i used to have a stutter and then
someone let me read shakespeare like
james earl jones
um i never did all of my
all of my acting i had like a theater
class but i mean it wasn't like we teach
you how to act it was just kind of we
teach you about theater
well don't take this the wrong way i
recommend it i think uh you should
seriously consider some acting lessons
no i agree
i i took i when i got to l.a
i was dating a girl this is so great i
dated a girl and i was like i'm gonna go
to your acting class
there's been two like sitting down with
an acting coach
that has really really helped me but
honestly the way that i've been able to
learn how to do this at least my way of
doing it is because i've had people that
have been gracious enough to put me in a
situation where they're like
here's the bumper rails on on like
bowling and you can [ __ ] up all you want
and we're gonna we we have a vested
interest in this thing looking good
and every time i just learn to [ __ ] up
less and less or at least [ __ ] up in
better ways
but that has been that actually is
pretty profound though i have to say
like that
because i i get i get asked a lot by
young kids if they need to go
get a music degree or if they like if
they want to get into games or get into
composing in general and they're like 18
saying do i have to go study formally
and get music theory and all that and i
what you just said is essentially what i
always tell them like if you can manage
to get a job
with with someone who's you know
they're in it with you and not just
looking for a transaction
you'll learn more from your mistakes
that you can hopefully
redirect before the project is over in
that one thing then probably an entire
university yeah i studied uh journalism
people always ask me if they need to and
i'm like i would recommend it in lieu of
you having other things to do in the
meantime to work towards this goal which
is kind of when i did it
but uh i am the least educated person on
this panel
absolutely like i've always said that
about you sorry also i need to introduce
mike
hi mike he is a game director how long
have you been doing your things for mike
i mean i started making games when i was
like
i guess seven because i was a really
cool kid um
yeah i was coding like from like seven
eight years old yeah and what
like what was the language i was using
no no like q basic which is like anyone
who's a coder will know that that's not
like a very advanced programming
language but yeah i was using like q
basic a bit of basic
um yeah and then but in terms of like
doing it properly and being paid
uh about 14 years now wait at
seven years old how did you do that like
i said troye was just a really cool kid
i had lots of friends
i have a friend uh
i played with gi joe and she's like she
was like seven when she published the
game she published this map game
on steam i wouldn't be really clear i
was they weren't good games troy these
were not award winners
it doesn't matter like i just i
i don't know how that like because i was
playing with i was playing my gi joe or
my transformers
in the backyard and i had a computer
like
i grew up in the 80s and early 90s and
like my dad
had a computer an ordinary in france uh
french um but it was either a green
screen or
an orange screen but like i wasn't going
in
i was learning how to play games i was
playing so i had i had a big advantage
in the so i'm second generation coder so
my dad was a programmer as well so he's
bringing home computers something we did
together my father
my father in this outfit
and his father before him and you're
gonna be a coder too you hear me
but like if we want to talk about like
misadjusted youth my favorite fact about
my childhood
there are many is um i've missed out on
a lot of my
what what would you call primary school
in america so kind of from the age of
like
okay
i would be able to do that if i was
wearing a dressing gown i'm going to
keep mentioning it so you have to leave
the the um uh
yes i i've missed out on a lot of my
little elementary education because
uh i was the only kid in the school that
knew how computers worked so whenever
there was a tech problem i would be
taken out of class
wait you were the i.t i was the it guy
at my elevator
no way so there are so many kids
settings it comes up like once every
five years i'll just be having a
conversation with someone and it'll turn
out like that i don't know
like something really rudimentary like
division it's not that
like can't tell the time there'll be
something like
just something that everyone would know
you've been mislabeling blue and red
you've been reversed on those for the
last 20 years and
uh no one's ever told you really weird
like rudimentary skills like missing
wow you literally just used me as tech
support yeah well i like how we got into
our back stories at episode 22.
22. i [ __ ] mislabeled this wrong this
is the ball episode with all the
flashbacks that you get to like once
you're wearing a robe everything's off
kill though i don't know what we're
doing
uh what i what i uh what i love is the
george costanza-ness of you being you're
you're ensconced in velvet right now you
you've definitely
you've got the you've got the my my
comfort
gives no [ __ ] to anything else and it's
just
hats i've been i've been i've gone to
every meeting i had today dressed like
this
goddamn right that you have beautiful
wait is it not just like
hot where you are i live in england troy
i live in england so i've been called
it's it's been hot like it was like
one of the last times i was there in the
summer it was like 40 41 it was hot
yeah you know what else is hot it's
quite cool today gin's awesome when he
gets in
all right
uh also after last week uh i believe the
colloquial term for it is sushi no it
isn't playing sushi
now feels wrong that feels like
something
i've been calling it ghost i think ghost
works also ghost but i think
sushi is cute so you know you win
something
no uh have you guys all played it
yes there's
who's going first you i guess because
you were speaking
um that
like epilah or prologue that happens and
then
that's one of the best like opening um
sequences like when it cuts that guy
huh he burned that guy first of all he
he can do no wrong to me i loved him in
deadwood
but just the way that he came out is
just like uh he's fantastic
really good villain he if i haven't
gotten to the game yet but if they can
get one [ __ ] out of him i will be
so happy just because that is or if he
says
i mean hang die wouldn't say well i
guess he could say hang dai uh
if you're not a deadwood fan you have no
idea what i'm talking about but
um but just that the not only is that it
felt like
uh to me force unleashed where you
started off as such a badass
and i felt like i could do anything and
then we're gonna like slowly reduce back
until you
gain up um i have a i have a
total confession i thought it was ghost
of tsushima
so when he dies to me
on the beach i was like oh cool i'm
going to be a ghost
and like yoona's the only one that can
see you so i thought it was a literal
ghost i was like that can see this
happen like you can get supernatural
abilities
you'll be able to like and there's like
no no no it's just
like a metaphor and allegory i was like
oh never mind
amazing the the the thing that um
i'm just talking about like when that
sweeping swelling score comes up and
you're riding through that field and it
was like goes to sushi i was like
i got goosebumps i was like i am in this
is going to be an epic adventure
i was so ready for it a lot of people
have been saying it's a perfect palette
cleanser after coming off the last of us
part two
towards just like right um the best
description that i've heard
and i i i scan with this completely
um it is assassin's creed
meets red dead redemption with a little
sprinkle blend of red dead redemption
with shadow of mordor heavy
uh and breath of the wild yeah all of
those things to me is like that
this to me the best part about it um and
that there's a mechanic that they use
with the assassination that i thought is
is really really cool it was like
here's something that which feels like a
sucker punch game but it's really a
weird choice to do it's a dangerous
choice to do
where you say here's a mechanic that is
fundamentally
diametrically opposed to the character
do you want to do that that's super
dangerous to do
um and the fact that they balance that
really really well
this feels to me like sucker punch spent
the last
six years really thinking about who they
are as a studio what kind of game they
want to make
and iterating iterating iterating
iterating iterating iterating iterating
polish polish polish polish polish
polish polish
it is just such an uh a huge step up
from even second sun um
one of the i i mean i i agree with
literally everything that you said i got
chills in that opening sequence as well
i totally agree with red dead breath of
the wild
uh mortal is an assassin's creed is the
perfect way to describe it it takes
little pieces from all those
one thing that um a lot of people
criticize it is also driven me nuts is
the lip sync is off
yeah uh including with the english so
yeah how like i don't know if that's a
question you can answer
how does that happen i mean that
that to me feels like an engine problem
interesting
issue you're saying are you saying with
the english second sorry
the amounts don't move in sync with what
they're saying even in the english
version
um and i played my first time in
japanese and that it is it is weird
playing a game with japanese people in
japan but their mouths are moving for
english but they're speaking japanese
it's strange but you know
it's funny i assumed i assumed that when
i was noticing that
that it was because they had recorded
everything in japanese and that the
english was essentially an overdub
exactly like a movie i assumed that that
was the case if you go to japanese it's
not in sync then either
no i don't think the amount of reported
in japanese i don't think they recorded
in japanese i think that they would have
recorded english
yeah i think they i think they shot in
in english and dubbed in japanese would
be my guess yeah
i'm gonna have a conversation with
daisuke um who played jen
and i'm gonna ask him that he was
streaming last night and it was
so good yeah there's this part where he
finally sees his own butt and he goes
yeah why am i saying yeah in my own arse
he's very very sweet to watch yeah he's
a really good guy
the thing that sucker punch did um and
it started i think
with um with second sun like every day
that we would go into
set we went down and did the most
intense facial scan
that i'd ever done because they wanted
likeness
um and once we knew there were gonna be
a launch title for the ps4 they're like
we're gonna be able to have the fidelity
that we really really want
so they actually made there's a company
that did this for
tron and there was every morning we
would see jeff bridges face
um which is super creepy and the same
place that we were and it was basically
a michael myers mask kind of thing where
it was this clear
i mean 3d mold of our face that they had
drilled
all the holes and so we would lie back
in the makeup chair
and then for about 15 minutes they would
put this thing to our face they would
just go boop boop
and point as opposed to just what they
do now which is just a steady hand and
an
eyeliner pencil actually is what um puts
it on
so it was this really rigorous process
but if you looked at
the like a close-up version of the model
it's like holy [ __ ] that the fidelity is
great the problem is once you get that
in
in engine you have the like advanced
warfare thing
and a lot of people did this where it's
like those models look great in their
cinematics and then they go to the end
game and it's like this huge disparity
between those two
i feel like what they did was there's a
couple of money shots that they used
where they put a lot of money and
resources behind those great shots
because the models look great
but then by and large as a philosophical
choice
they said it's far more important
important for us
to make sure that we're using as close
to the models as we can both in
cinematics and in engine
even if that means it looks a little
early ps4
um then try to really really crank this
you know this engine to to they could
spend their resources in other places
it's a huge open world game there's a
lot of other things that they need to
serve
other than the models looking like one
to one it might would you agree
that's probably what happened in terms
of meshes yeah in terms of
in terms of like the specifics of the
lip sync i actually don't think they're
doing a lot of mocap lip sync that's my
read
i think i think as you say they're doing
that for like you're that that great
epilogue cutscene a few other places
but i think the bulk of it they're using
an automation process
which they shot a lot i know i know for
a fact that they
shot a lot but there's also a lot of
stuff that happens in the shadow of
mordor kind of
presentation i was going to refer to
shadow of mordor because shadow of
mordor was brilliant in two supports
yeah but but well either of them used
amazing automation
um which is which is an off-the-shelf
solution now that i mean
i've taken a couple of meetings with
them and they they always show the video
of the orcs from that stuff
but this is automated lip sync so
automated facial performance so what you
do is you capture
kind of the key facial expressions and
the key phenomes from
from from you guys from the actors and
then essentially you automate you can
basically it's kind of like stitching
those together to make performances
it's good enough in a lot of cases and
for like open world games where you just
have so much content
it is a it is a system that can be used
i feel like a lot of what i'm seeing in
ghosts is using that approach and then
the the actual kind of
the performance driven lip sync is being
used in very specific places for cut
scenes that are
of high value there's a very noticeable
jump in quality
every now and again for one of those the
big there's actually three tiers from
what i can tell there's like
the amazing pre-rendered cutscene which
is the epilogue and the few others
you've got um a swan which is a simple
kind of character art swap out which is
kind of the
naughty dogger excellence of this the
kind of the swap out of the high res for
the
for the for the cutscene and then you've
got what we used to be called camera
cases but i think that's an outdated
task now where they're literally using
the character the in-game character
model for some of the cutscenes as well
so when you're uh for side quests for
example that
mid shot where you've got you talking
that's just the gay in-game character
model and honestly in terms of like
the facial stuff that's going on in that
model probably you've only got a few
bones to do facial animation so you're
literally just raising and lowering
eyebrows and talking like this and
they also cut into a wide camera a lot
of times too they'll do that to hide it
there's something that just in people
watching me don't know like when you go
to phenoms
it's like they literally there used to
be a phrase that we would say it's kind
of like the
the quick brown fox jumped over the lazy
dog is something you can use every
you know letter on the keyboard there
was the same thing that we would do
and it was like old delilah brings some
butter there was like all these things
that would exactly what mike's doing it
would make your face move in such a way
actually i think mike's just having a
medical issue yes
it's the robe it's cutting off the
circulation like we did
we did for second son and we've done
this for multiple games
um last of us part two included
um we would go down it was about two
days uh and i've done this
literally almost everywhere in the world
um
where we would go in and it's make you
know
scrunch off your face now big you're
basically ellie and the mirror at the
museum
yes so you have to go and
but like just raise your upper lip but
don't scrunch your nose and it's
literally you do
all of these things so they go that's
what troy looks like
when we do this which means that's what
italian looks like which means that's
what delson looks like or joel looks
like whatever
but it is literally before it was just
to help them
match so it's like if we don't really
capture that angry scale that you get in
the cinematic we can refer to this
as a reference model and hand animators
can come and do this
what mike's saying now and what i've
actually seen happen now
is what that means is what they're doing
is we now have
that facial expression in a bank that we
can use
and just record vo apply it to the
character model
apply that to the face and we have as
near perfect to
a cinematic performance
it's however you walk out i think
outside of cutscenes they got cut scenes
as well yes you well know you directed
them
like the cutscenes were done with with
with real performance but
literally everything else is basically
taking voice over
and then doing a bunch of simulation
work to basically work out
how to get that and then i go in as a
as an editor and i go oh the orcs angry
during this bit and sad
and it kind of does the the facial
expression and it's usually something
called morph targets in a lot of cases
so for
uh when you're seeing like a character
animate on screen and they're making
different shapes for their mouth
it's not like a skeletal system which is
how you do sometimes it's a skeletal
system but
usually it's more targeted so skeleton
is how you move your arm and it's
please stop me if i'm getting boring by
the way um like how you move your arm is
defined by a skeleton
um which is in the character and then
you you you basically are pulling that
figure around morph targets are
different and
essentially it's like troy said you've
they've made a model of your face doing
every phenome
and then they're basically kind of doing
like a morph and a blend
on that mesh and warping the mesh
basically to match that where it gets
really cool now
in your aaa productions is they're doing
that as well in the textures which is
where you get the scrunch on the nose
and stuff like that coming in
because they're fading those up and down
as they move the parts of the face
and that's you know that's ridiculous
and in um
movie animation it even gets like
stretching pause and squishing pause and
actually
changing now the surface of the the skin
works
it's almost uh it's almost reminiscent
of the
the tech they use and the mission
impossible movies you know where he's
like
sampling a few key phrases in order to
make the voice box thing and build
and build the masks like
that's
a little fighter i don't want to hurt
her
so unsettling troy i'm like what
it's so good it's so good his
face when they push him out the airplane
where he's
just on flight he's just staring at i
was just like
ah man just the choice to be able to do
that is just genius
oh so much as he was for any actor who
brings that much game to like
genre stuff like he click he did not
think he was above the material he
committed and he went for it i respect
that and the fact that he
really thought he was like i i even
though
that gorgeous gorgeous
runway model is totally out of my league
i can go home with her i was like the
level of confidence he had as that
character was just like
and one of the i'm sorry one more thing
i'll leave it alone it's one of tom
cruise's best performances too
he has one scene with uh bridget
moynihan i believe it was who played
michelle monahan michelle mohan sorry
hey you know
um where he goes i'm obsessed with the
mission impossible movies
okay they all the greatest movies when
he when he looks at her
and says i need you to trust me she goes
like he goes
i need you to trust me i was like oh
give that man an uh that one moment
singular moment right there is amazing
i'll shut up about tom cruise and
philip seymour hoffman he's pretty good
at what he does that tom cruise pretty
good at what he does he's never bad
one day he's going to get a break
seriously one day that guy's going to
get a roll that people really get behind
like
one thing he's been bad in
not a baby i love him in tropic thunder
so much he's fantastic he's so so
good because it's something that you
would never expect him to do yeah the
thing that i the thing that i love about
of ages he's still good in it it's a
shame
but he he's actually you know what no he
is his knees
i didn't take much convincing yeah i
know you're right
oh sorry go ahead austin well all i was
all i was gonna say is
through through the lens of my uh word
of mouth
he uh who is wow no stripes socks today
i know um i am anymore
he uh he would always show up at the
orchestra
recording sessions for his movies um and
and
and
not to not to to like
um steal the focus or to make it about
him
it was like as the headliner inevitably
and the and one of the producers he
takes that role seriously
and i've always heard from from folks
that are
that were working on those on those
films that that um
you know he really he is he's invested
he comes to director sessions for cue
playback um um and and again some
producers are there to just throw their
weight around but he's like
i i care i saw an interview with him
where he said he seems like a real fan
of cinema right
i i get that impression i i obviously i
i've
never met him but i don't know much
about him uh but i do
i did once seen an interview with him
where he described it as
um like a sacred trust he goes if if
there's a movie that i'm starring in
that's in theaters and someone's going
to go pay 10 bucks or whatever to go see
it
they're basically trusting me with their
two hours and i
don't take that lightly and so it's like
every detail of this needs to be
everything that i could possibly offer
up to make that
a justifiable use of their time and
money and i feel like he really lives
that
you know it's like all the scientology
stuff he may be he may be
uh completely off the rails uh in
certain aspects but professionally
he's so committed and he's so good yeah
i feel like i like him in ghost protocol
which reminds me of the game ghost of
tsushima which
i personally think which mike what did
you think of it
i i like it i think it
it definitely has a very strong opening
i mean that's absolutely like undeniable
i think as it goes on
it's it's a little sparser it doesn't
it kind of feels like it's in the kind
of the day's gone the kind of shadow
shadow of mordor kind of scale of open
world game where it's kind of
or mad max it kind of has it feels a
little bit
smaller than i would expect from like a
first penalty but like i i
i thoroughly enjoy it like and then i
think crucially it's just the exact game
i need right now
like psychologically it feels like it is
a game
in in in kind of with respect the way
last of us two probably wasn't the kind
of game that my psyche needed right now
like it's
goes to team is a a very relaxed it's
pleasant
and i think that's it's it's the game of
the moment in that sense i think it's
the right game for me to be playing
right now
it's relaxing to me on that but yeah
mechanically i love it i love the pace
of the combat i think that's fantastic
that kind of it really is
enough kind of thing it's just so cool
you press a button and they come out to
fight you i love that stuff yeah but
i sold it to a friend of mine based
entirely on the existence of barn i was
like you're gonna like this game and
i'll tell you why
there is a button you press that button
i keep jumping in i'm sorry but it's
like assassin's creed to the thing where
it's like ah just kind of like
that parrying though is crucial
and when you actually get it right and
you find that rhythm people are talking
about it's kind of like arkham combat
systems like not
at all it it is way more i feel like i'm
more connected to jyn
when i'm fighting because it is all
about precision
and timing as opposed to just rhythm um
i think
i mean i feel like it's it's alchemy
in so far as you're right it's not about
rhythm
uh but it is still about
a flow there it feels like a dance in a
lot of ways to me
uh the thing that gets me though is i
don't get perfect parries all that often
i get good parries
but not perfect parries so every time
that you do you're like yes nailed down
wait a minute i don't i haven't seen the
difference between a perfect period in
the
just a regular parry um the perfect pair
is the one where it actually slows down
but you can still effectively parry and
come back off uh yeah that's what a
perfect parrot kind of looks like when
you get a perfect one
but there are also i'm terrible at
parrying so
i'm definitely i'm i'm i'm over relying
on the roll
i'm i'm rolling around in front of every
villain i'm but i'm
relatively i'm early in the game story
so i think i've not
gotten all the cool stuff but yeah yeah
you get a lot of upgrades i went back
and i started the game from the
beginning again
and it was so difficult because at the
start you don't even have the
assassinate ability
really hard to go back and start it
again and be like oh my god i don't have
anything useful you i feel like you
progressed pretty slowly
but don't worry you know i was gonna say
don't you
if you assassinate too much then he
comes to you and he's like you're doing
this wrong
i got a cut scene that told me i was
killing too many people via
assassination
which i thought was really interesting
as opposed to it it is a really
interesting choice yeah
i mean to cap it you know because they
always had the karma system so it was
like
they rewarded the player for going like
you know
douche bag or hero and
to to cap it that way and going you're
doing too much it was like oh
it's like i'm kidding
it was just a really quick kind of
flashback to like my uncle
saying this is you shouldn't be killing
people
okay i did have a flashback when i
started using poison and they were like
we don't overuse this
but i didn't know that like that might
be sort of unscripted i think it's
doing some kind of tracking or so that's
what
one thing i love about it which is again
like we're talking about brave choices
in this game like this is a really brave
choice the
the movement away from metrics is really
interesting like the way
there's no xp there is xp there's 100 an
xp system working under the hood there's
100 of the level ups
but i'm not seeing numbers i'm not
seeing
uh that that kind of thing is not
encroaching on my experience i'm
building a legend
the obvious i know the numbers i need
which is this is going to do it a little
bit it's going to do it a big bit on the
menu you get that kind of intro but i
love that there's no numbers
yeah i have no idea the first um
the first the first like statement of
that that i think the game makes is the
lack of the
in-game mini-map uh like where it's
basically you follow the wind right
and that takes some getting used to did
anyone else i found that so frustrating
for the first like
oh my god no i loved it immediately oh
no it took me a while i was annoyed of
like
so where exactly am i meant to be going
but then the second it kicked in i was
like i could i just got
i got forgive me a little zen like i got
a little like relaxed into it i got kind
of
i learned to play the game in its own
rhythm a little bit and i think that got
it it seems like conflict for me it's
funny how it seems like they're going
out of their way
because of that because of like you said
the lack of
on-screen xp and things like that
they're going out of their way to make
it feel as minimally video gamey as
possible but then the funny thing is
that
in other ways it's very video gamey like
i've been out here collecting flowers to
buy hats come on
why you do it i i didn't know what i was
like it's hats and
hats and dies right yeah sorry continue
austin
yeah yeah well i i because i i find
there's a little bit of schizophrenia in
that because i do love the as mike says
there's a i love the zen
quality of the game it's it's like
immersive it's maybe even
the better word for it where the game
the game sort of emotionally
frames the experience and then isn't
pulling me out with
data or x you know xp
like oh that kind of guy is worth that
much versus that i earned that
surely like that's my thing because i
always really rebel against
i hate it is but i hate it when games
do the whole we're going to be immersive
so no ui screw you it's a video game
like give me the information it's it i
find that genuinely annoying in a lot of
games where they
where it feels like they're just kind of
um arbitrarily removing that stuff
whereas this seems
it feels very finely calibrated like
we're going to give you what you need
and want at any moment but we're going
to pull the rest of it away
yeah i don't know whether oh dude i did
that's hard yeah oh it's not like they
pull everything off
yeah you can't even see like the like
the vendors
um and i still do it fairly often and i
actually do really like it in this game
because they do a good job with visual
language
like directing you everywhere but if you
do that with kurosawa mode
that's like that's like
you don't even get red icons for when
you're being attacked like that makes
stuff super hard yeah
it still lights up but it just doesn't
there's
there like you said there is no red icon
but it is like if you do that with like
expert mode and you turn off everything
to where there's just
it is literally just playing like a
movie it's dope but it's like
this is fun for photo mode that's about
it
i have to i have to also say just one of
the first things that you mentioned troy
that for me
was great because a lot of games
struggled with this in terms of the
narrative is how to reconcile
the idea that your character is supposed
to be this badass
but we have to tutorialize the player
into our systems and this has been
a constant challenge i think i've always
found
most of the solutions to this to be very
kind of necessary evil but they they do
pull me out of the game where they they
rely on like
an amnesia storyline or something in
order to kind of
get the player you know like i thought
fall in order uh
you know did it reasonably well but but
it's always an issue if you want to have
especially in a game like this you want
to have some kick-ass
opening prologue thing that really gives
you that taste and
and um force unleashed obviously had
that same
same quality but for me the idea that
um the the the the palm days is just
unlocking these powers but it's not
selling the idea that gin doesn't know
them
and so the idea so i loved that because
to me that felt like as organic a
solution as i could think of where
he is still young so of course he's
still going to be learning but
he's he knows more than i do as a player
and we flash back to when he's like a
teenager learning from his uncle
i thought that's a really great way to
wrap
narrative and tutorialization together
because obviously and i'm also now
investing in the relationship with the
uncle at the same time and i was like
man that's
that's really elegant for for a game
that has to be so driven by
systems and just learning all the
different sort of tools in your
in your on your palette um it makes yeah
it makes that tutorial feel emotional in
a really interesting way and you know
feeding into trying to rescue your uncle
or whatever and then every flashback you
get is your uncle telling you about this
honorable code that you have to live by
and then the
you trying to get your uncle back
results in you breaking that honorable
code
yeah yeah i'm very into those themes i
hope they're building on those themes
i've not got very far in the story i'm
hoping that as it goes on they actually
kind of i would love to actually see it
play with that because it feels
because i'm honestly quite bored of like
video games doing the whole
force you to kill someone and then
telling you off for having done the
thing that you had to do easy
easy hey hey we're not naming names here
we're not naming names
here however but no but like with
with this one like that is a choice like
you don't need you can play the entire
thing as an honorable samurai and never
stab anyone in the back
so i am making a choice there and i like
the idea of the game actually
interrogating me a little on that that's
fun
it's still sucker it's still like
insulting you for pressing a button
but yeah you're right it's a sucker
punching it's the morality system but
just feels more organic than that kind
of
bar this feels this feels so much more
like
like again like an evolution for sucker
punch to go got it this is what our
karma system is now because i even told
them this
with second son i was like you are
building you're you're allowing them
this mechanic to dictate your game
and you're shoehorning in this kind of
narrative
and i'm not being disparaging but i'd
never wanted to be a
you can't have delson be like this i
want to do good
but then i'm going to be this dick like
coal
made sense he was like i'm not a hero
i'm a ruthless guy and i will either go
take this path to accomplish my goal or
this path
but delson was like he had the loss of
his brother he had all these things he
wanted to protect his village
so it it made sense for him to do like
the heroic thing
what didn't make sense was for him to be
an [ __ ] and that's kind of what you
have to do in
to go fully read you got to be an
[ __ ] this so far is like man there
was a code there was an honorable way
and i know in order to accomplish this
goal i may have to do stuff that
sacrifices that
but like even the way that they do my
favorite mechanic is
and the way they tutorialize it is so
great it was like find your resolve
i'm like oh that because it's a cheap
punt you're picking up flowers and doing
and
supplies everywhere and iron everywhere
to be able to go here's a health pack
here's food like go get some rice balls
you know you can pull the kurosawa you
know tip of the hat to them
with that or millet you know but to be
able to go you're not ready yet find
your resolve that to me is a fantastic
narrativized uh mechanic that they did a
great job
cool it's a little bit of wobble with
the morale moral aspect
i like i'm i'm hoping it continues to do
that as it goes on which is cool
it's also cheaper it's worth saying and
that's that's as a game dev like i feel
the need to point this out like
not having to do two sets of cutscenes
really great that's like super
super uh time saves money because you
all
you're making and this is always the
debate you have in game development of
like
you're making a bunch of content you
want to give players meaningful choices
but you're also fully aware that you're
paying for a bunch of stuff and the
players paying for a bunch of stuff that
they're not going to see by definition
like if i've never seen the evil aspect
of any of uh
any of those of the infamous games
because i always play good
so i'm by definition paying for content
that i've not seen and that's a choice
like
well actually but like putting the money
where the player's eyes are is a really
interesting
because that's because if you go too far
down that road you end up making a game
that's very linear
and people don't get enough choice and
don't feel the value that way
so it's always a balancing act of like
they did it for replayability just like
play it blue play it red
this is but this is a this is an
interesting hearkening back to
our our conversation last time but an
area of it that we didn't actually get
into
i would argue that i'm not paying for
content i'm paying for the choice
and so it's not true it's not a lack of
it's not wasted resources to miss out on
the things that i'm
opting out of it's actually
justification
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute it's a balancing
you're not paying for content you're
paying for
choice no like i understand he's saying
that he's not paying for
the option he's not paying just it's the
knowledge that it's there
he's he's paying for the option to have
both but choose the one that he wants
yeah exactly that's his choice gets
value because of that
but do you not want replayability i'm
not pushing against this i'm trying to
understand it but do you do you not feel
that replayability is important
i mean i don't yeah i i so it's
definitely like replayability if we want
to i mean if we've got another hour
replayability is like the the least
important
from a players from from the player's
perspective it's really important but
the number of players who actually
replay games is
[ __ ] tiny like it's finished
exactly right so it's a perceived thing
it matters to the player the player
wants to know they have the opportunity
to replay
but they often don't take that
opportunity you know but there's a
difference between
like um gta perfect example
maximum replayability that thing doesn't
leave your drive
it stays in there you play it
well you probably down look i gold i
always have gta downloaded i gold did
all of the missions
but i don't think i'll ever play through
that single player campaign again
sometimes i'll pick it up and have fun
with it but i'm not going to replay that
game
do you think and gta is just anomalous
thing so it may not work do you think
that
where do you think the expense for gta
or even go suzushima
lies is it in is it the most expensive
thing to do is the cinematic
or is it in the the rest of the game
well so for the conversations i've had
with sucker punch it is the open world
that is where their resources went um it
is also worth noting that they are
much smaller team than any of the other
first party studios they're like
which is the which is like the this is
that's the kind of the mad max shadow of
war
kind of aspect of it like it feels like
a scope that fits that team
yeah they are smaller and i feel like uh
that's something that is worth
noting um and i think that cinematics is
also something that they have
historically not been as strong at as
they are in open worlds they shine in an
open world so
yeah the the money and animation and
physics like billy harper is a [ __ ]
genius that guy is like true
and he's the most innocuous like
colombo-esque kind of guy
because he's the kentucky backwoods dude
that
looks like he's 26 and he's older than
me and he's he's a genius
he's a visionary genius um
and brian fleming literally a genius
like that guy
does math problems for fun he's just
he's next level um and he's the one that
is on
you would think that that guy is is the
one that you go to for all the cognitive
stuff
and he is the one that is like infusing
the most heart into all of their games
um i love brian fleming brian fleming
has been one of the most influential
people that i've ever worked with um i'm
a big fan of the studio in general and
everyone i've ever met there but
this applies to a lot of studios frankly
um i really like what they do and
again the thing with this open wall is
that i just keep
i love the wind system so much but also
the birds and the foxes and
the sound design where all of that stuff
is concerned but i keep being like man
please other studios if we talk about
theft and game design steal
this i love the way that the game guides
you
sorry mike it encourages sorry i know
it's totally my fault i interrupted you
encourages wandering it encourages you
just to go and
wander in a way that i've not like i was
thinking about this like since like
there was an indie game called proteus
uh yeah and
i i don't think i've felt that way in
the game since then of kind of i'm just
going to go over there
why what are you trying to unlock
nothing that's just i'm interested in
what's over there breath of the wild
so i never got into breath of the wild
much i was because i well to be honest i
wasn't given the option too much because
my girlfriend was so into it that
this which was not unavailable to me
but the uh but yeah like i've heard that
about breath of the wild as well so i do
need to get to it at some point but no
this one just jumped
out to me as like you know that i love
that but you also have to have a very
pretty open world to justify it and i
think go sushima does it's also just
like little touches where
if you're riding through i don't even
know what they would be called like the
long grass that has the like
white flowers i don't know on the top
gin will just wrap
his hand down yeah just sort of touch
them and like little touches like that
that i just i just find this world
so so so stunning and so easy to get
lost in that it shows that that's where
sucker punch puts their money and that's
what they
ultimately specialize it's smart as well
because that photo mode and that
that that virality that we're seeing on
social media is like
isn't it is that funny there's a great
business case for that as well isn't it
funny how the
how the um things like you're mentioning
alana with reaching down and touching
the grass and like the fact that
one of the first things i saw from
people like the day it came out i think
the first tweet that i caught from
someone playing it
was them saying can i just play only
can i have a game where all i do is
follow foxes uh
and like they're just loving that so
much as it's
almost like a quasi mini game within the
game
is kind of that yeah but without the
open world yeah
yeah the uh big the but to me that the
thing that's so interesting
that i'm i'm kind of i'm still i'm like
like mike i'm
i'm only maybe three hours in or so i've
i feel like i've kind of barely
scratched the surface
but um um but i
uh the thing that i find interesting
that actually is working for me
even though you would think it wouldn't
based on
how i'm gonna describe it because
there's kind of a hard schism between
that the this meditative really
really just just squeezing the beauty
out of everything that it can
and then it's also quite vicious and
violent and
and uh and kind of brutal uh
and and uncompromising there you can
execute people
yeah and like if you die it takes ages
yeah oh my god yeah they they relish in
in killing you or like what like
surrounding you and then oh that's the
guy that's gonna finish me off and he
isn't even the one that killed me
initially
like there's a lot of that and it's so
it's interesting that it
you would think it wouldn't work that um
that it's that it would have this sort
of almost split personality of
very tranquil introspective
gorgeousness and then just this brutal
but
somehow those two are kind of
alchemizing you've just described you've
just described like the pop culture
understanding of samurai right like it's
it's i i don't know enough about the
period in history to know how realistic
it is but
if you think about samurai you think of
like thoughtful
like jedi warriors right like thoughtful
philosophers
who wander through the woods and
occasionally murder someone horrifically
like
but that's what they are in pop culture
thanks to true or so
yeah but what's so great yeah kurosawa
what he and and
and what's so great about i just
recently watched
seven samurai i did it again as well
yeah [ __ ]
three hour and 26 minute movie and the
main thing you can learn from that movie
is
if you hide behind three hour 26 minutes
and kurosawa was like
[ __ ] editors man all my shots stay
um behind a door or a tree
that's the best that's the best strategy
hiding behind a door or a tree is the
best strategy rice
is super important
in the game they make rice and much
better than millet much better yeah much
better
if you have a pot you hug it all night
um you don't need to have pants to go to
battle
um and watch out for spears in your butt
the the thing that i found interesting
they're all just good life lessons you
hold the sword like that
you hold a sword yeah just like this and
it's super long
um the the thing that i found
interesting was
the uh the soundtrack that i had
expected
not for ghost of tsushima but for seven
samurai
was way different and
it's in the same way it's an area where
it's really aged right like sound design
has come a long way since
since seven samurai not to not to knock
it but like
you could it definitely shows its age in
that aspect you can definitely tell it's
a movie from
what the 50s 54 but i mean there's other
movies that came out in 1954
like you could even go back to uh gone
with the win was 49
is that right 48. yeah but some stuff
had happened in japan in the preceding
decade i think that limited their access
to um
like it was it was like it was they were
otherwise occupied
right busy at the time well sure but in
1954
um i don't i don't know what
do you have have you listened to the
soundtrack or uh what's your name
scott austin i always confuse which a
i am uh i'm actually i'm actually kind
of proud that it's worked out that way
that makes me feel
because you and austin are old old
friends that feels really bad
that's why i forget his name wait have
you listened to the soundtrack for seven
samurai
uh yeah not in ages but yeah um
performance wise it's like
like i i could see you going okay uh
trump trombones we're gonna hit that one
more time
you know interesting it's true of a lot
of it's true of a lot of
early like i i actually started to
notice that kind of thing when
i first around maybe age um
1718 is i became pretty i guess a little
earlier than that became pretty hardcore
into
soundtrack collecting and that was right
around the time that there ended up
being this
like union rules and things relaxed a
little bit and so they were able to go
back and release a lot of things that
had never been released in the past and
especially music from tv
um that was just like locked up you know
all these
classic shows and even utterly not
classic shows but they had great
composers
um involved and one of the things that
you consistently find that i think is
also
in evidence here is that this stuff was
often slapped together really fast
and no one ever expected there to be a
soundtrack album where you could
scrutinize it outside of the context of
the film or the tv show
so all those blemishes uh were
largely uh less noticeable and
and and now it's sort of like horrifying
and embarrassing
now there's just the presumption that
everything will get released basically
and also it's just it's it's easier you
know the fact that we're not recording
to tape and time on the studio means
um you know an expense of resources in a
very different way you know the the
around 2000 ish when everything really
made the leap to be fully digital
that made a massive massive difference
in terms of the minimum bar for quality
that we're able to offer because yeah
it's just like
you only have so many takes before
you've expended your tape
budget and and so it's like i guess that
was it number three and we'll try to
literally get out our razor blades and
cut that section
from that tape onto this tape in order
to salvage it but
the the techniques were very limited
and so yeah goes to tsushima had two
composers
it does have two composers yeah there's
a there's a composer based in london
named ilan ishkeri
who has mostly done movies and tv
although he has done
quite a bit of games including almost
all of the sims um which is a very funny
like very different non-sequitur link
yeah
so very why would they have had
two what's the purpose of that well so
shigeru umebayashi
is the other composer who is basically a
very traditional japanese film composer
and to my knowledge this is the only
game he's ever done although i could be
wrong about that but
generally the way that those would work
which is kind of like the way it worked
on the last of us
part two with gustavo centalia and
uh the composer of the tv show mr robot
matt quail who did the other part of the
score
uh the the way that it worked is
essentially things that are systemic
you know combat music a lot of the you
know quest related things like that
is generally handled by the person who's
more fluent in those systems and kind of
able to iterate a lot more closely with
the developers typically this is what
you find so like
combat i think almost i think all the
combat music in last of us part two was
by matt quail for example
um uh and um and in the same thing here
ilana scary
um is handling that kind of stuff and
then for
the cinematics and the big
presentational
scenes um like in for both games that's
where
they are leaning on the other composer
and so the way i don't know specifically
how it worked here but my assumption is
uh because i because sony has worked
this way a lot in the past
is that they'll have a composer
basically write a
succession of sweets kind of somewhat
detached from the game where they'll say
like okay look here take a look at some
of the artwork take a look at some of
the stuff now
go write 10 minutes just inspired by
that of what you would call heroic music
and now give us 10 minutes of what you
would call
tragic music or whatever the composer
throws that over the fence
and then they go and they they pull what
they need from it and they edit it and
they fit it into the game it's it's
the you only work that way when you're
working with someone who doesn't
self-identify as a game composer
basically because
yeah it's very much not scoring it's the
moriconi way of working where
he'll write he'll write a he'll read a
script uh and then just
throw a bunch of music at them and say
here's kind of the impression i got from
your script and have fun i'm moving on
to the next movie now
and uh and uh not scoring to picture at
all
and gustavo's saying the same thing to
my knowledge he didn't do
any he just kind of like what is that
what is at stake in this scene and what
do you need to
uh convey and they're like this like
okay so we're gonna kind of edit around
that
it's yeah there's it's very different uh
you know i remember
a friend of mine uh was the contractor
who who hired the orchestra on um
on uh on seemingly every major movie but
this particular
instance was he was working on indiana
jones
four i guess crystal skull the good one
the good one yeah we're back at that
troy's favorite
and uh but he said that
he said that uh you know they were in
the middle of recording one of these big
action sequences
and william john williams is conducting
the orchestra and then
you know it's like indy lands a punch
and the indie theme comes in right just
you know
and then gone back into all the you know
check it out i took it to check it out
orchestral acrobatics and and william
stops conducting and turned
to spielberg and goes
stephen should we start the theme
on the punch or should it be and land
the theme on the punch
uh because we can adjust that here and
spielberg's like oh the way you did it
is fine or something just like a little
moment in the working relationship
and that's the kind of thing where
williams is watching every frame of this
footage
and his sheet music is covered in
timings like on measure 27
that's where we cut to the wide shot of
indy on the motorcycle or whatever
and it's like it's so it's very much
film scoring
and in contrast to that it is
increasingly popular
you know for folks especially who are
coming into that world without that
background
um to just basically write boatloads of
music and then because of the incredible
ease of audio editing
find ways to just fit it and who does
that in game music
i hate to give it that qualifier but i
want to know who who would you say
scores like john williams does well
present company excluded no no
included well is there anything else
like yourself that does that yeah oh
absolutely yeah i mean gareth coker for
example a
friend of mine who did the ori games and
uh uh you know
that's very meticulously bespoke very
much
writing for the systems crafting the
systems around the game's needs instead
of
shoehorning in like okay well we have
combat but
it just works generically you know like
here's just loud fast music for combat
and
not getting into the nuances of what
makes this combat system different from
that and therefore
should the music do this or that you
know like on assassin's creed for
example we spent an enormous amount of
time
working out how the combat music was
going to function because the fact that
you can get into a fight
and be just about done with it but then
aggro some passer by
uh guy that's like that's a very
different thing than a sort of arena
fight mode fights over we go well so
that has huge implications for the music
if you care about that kind of stuff
so that's where a bear bear mccreary uh
you know that's an
example of uh you know like on god of
war um
i don't know exactly how he worked but i
suspect he and i are a lot alike in in
many in many ways and i know that he's
very much a gamer and very much
you know when he's scoring a game he is
a game composer and he really cares
about those systems
as well so whereas sony is perfectly
comfortable going to somebody and saying
just throw us stuff and we will you know
we've got a massive amazing
creative services group that can that
can make this stuff shine like in the
case of the last of us um
there are other composers that that will
get in the nitty-gritty with them it's
it's still
relatively uh rare
by comparison oh you know who another
great example is who takes this [ __ ]
incredibly seriously that
probably should have been the first uh
name out of my mouth because we spent
two hours talking about it on the dice
podcast
is uh olivier de riviere who scored
uh plaguetale which alana has played i'm
sure
uh and um he he is someone that
that's all he cares about like it's even
funny if you listen to our conversation
on the on the
on the game maker notebook he i would
start to ask him things about the
production you know like he'll
he's recorded a lot at abby road for
example and i'll start to ask him and he
will
he will actually not let me ask that
because he wants to get back to talking
about interactive systems and
the real art of game scoring it's like i
don't care about that stuff
i want to talk about i want to talk
about the nuances of interactivity
it is really interesting and players
also really do rely on it a lot like
probably more than
they give it credit for and i think the
sound design it goes to tsushima is a
great example of that is like i am
listening for birds
i am looking out for those things i am
waiting for the music to die down so
that i know that i've completed my task
and nobody else is going to attack me
i'm that way in
every game like as soon as i'm like ugh
i mean gizmo is a really good example is
like you literally wait for a guitar
sound
to know that a combat encounter is done
you're like okay cool we did it like you
you wait for that [ __ ] active cue
i have major love hate relationship with
this whole idea to me using music as a
sound effect
uh is always feels wrong to me it always
feels like you're using it's a sound
effect though i think it is a
but that you just scored even if it was
the system doing it
but that's that's right that's what
sound effects do in my estimation most
of the time there's always exceptions
but to me if you're scoring the mechanic
you're scoring the players experience
more than you're scoring the character's
experience and to me music
has a unique ability to bring power and
subjects subtext to the narrative
oh but dude if that was a like take take
that thing
and if i put that into a movie you guys
i really gotta go
so this is this are you serious yeah i
always have to finish at 12 every time
so i'm going to let you finish this and
then i have to run i'm just gonna say
like if there was a big
big action set piece in a movie you
would score the [ __ ] out of that and
then when it was done
there would be a big flourishing note to
let you know that thing was done
and then there's a moment of rest but
after it's the same thing i don't think
that's a sound effect i feel like that's
but you can't generalize about movies
like that like it depends entirely on
how the scene is
generally true but that would be only
because people make scenes like that
consistently
it's not because like oh the scene is
over therefore the music's over
no ronin is a great example great car
chase amazing car chase it's almost
completely silent
no music until they come out of the
tunnel and then there's music and you're
like holy [ __ ]
that's a great thing i i there's at this
point in the edit alana just slowly zoom
in on austin's face
his face is black and white and quiet
she's like anyone watching this just
rewind
super interesting take there austin like
i haven't heard you say that before like
this well yeah my
my number one my number one offender
that we can get into next time uh for
this was a game that i generally really
loved but it it it's
it's music system in this way really
actively
riled me up was la noire hold on so
remind me
remind me we'll talk about l.a noir
there are things that we could all say
about early noir like i feel like that
is such a uniquely made
game like the faces like it is
such an interesting game to talk about
sank the whole studio
we're gonna miss rock stars swinging a
miss i would really like to talk about
last of us next week mike mike
have we not i think i wanted to like
actually openly like
spoiler cast without me i'm playing
ghost of sushi
sashimi all right we'll figure it out
i'll come back that's the callback um
yep i gotta go so thank you we'll see
you next week